Anthony is in Canada
hi Anthony welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thanks for having me
sure what's up Joey so I earlier this
year I got really lucky and I won a
million dollars in the lottery and up
here in Canada you don't get taxed on it
so I got a check for a million dollars
and I was getting harassed by investment
people so I I got annoyed and I just
ended up paying off my mortgage and all
my debt and now like I found you way too
late in life and I'm discovering your
baby steps so I've sort of fast
forwarded to paying off my home early
but then I'm wondering how baby step 4
which is investing 15% of your household
income plays into baby step 7 which is
just building wealth and if there's
something else I should be doing now
yeah wow what an incredible deal how old
are you 35 what do you do for a living
I'm a lawyer
oh good okay what do you make uh well my
so I make 240 and then my wife is a
veterinarian and she makes about 90
working part-time right now so we were
you know we were blessed already kind of
working our way through our yeah I think
I didn't yeah wow this is all true this
is amazing this is kind of like a kick
Bologna while he's down show man
congratulations man this is awesome Wow
so you can make you're making tons of
money and you're a hundred percent
debt-free due to this lottery hit yes
okay cool
all right and what I gotta tell you what
actually spurred it was I was on YouTube
one night and I was looking at
Kirti shotguns and thinking how I could
never afford one of those fancy guns and
then lottery advertisement showed up on
YouTube so I went that night bought a
ticket checked it the next morning and
then found out that I won that's bizarre
so he played one time all
so I've bought tickets in the past you
know we'd be filling up for gas or
whatever on random occasions and this
one it was just for the moment that
night no well I don't I don't want this
call to encourage other people that do
this because it's not a proof of plan of
building wealth you just for freaking
lucky okay but I'm happy for you just
the same
so to acknowledge that too it is the
statistical and probability and I got
lucky yeah okay oh not okay so but
anyway I love ya I'm happy for you I'm
glad you've been blessed man so okay
there's three things that we can do with
money and I'm glad you guys are
continuing to work and continuing to
pursue your calling z' and continuing to
find dignity in doing what you're
trained to do that's wonderful keep
doing that keep earning the money and
there's three things we do with money
one we enjoy it and you need to do some
of that probably need to get that
shotgun if you didn't already and number
two you are outrageously generous which
you will find once you learn how to do
that with with care and intentionality
will become the most fun you ever have
with money and then the third thing is
we invest it and you should do that with
this fabulous income and you should do
that with whatever money is left after
paying off everything out of that
million dollars okay so have some fun
but and what I do is and what I suggest
to high-performing high-income producers
like athletes that we work with or the
occasional Hollywood type or whatever
that we run into and they're living this
weird amount of money dream I just say
listen put percentages on it set a
household budget that you're going to
run your household on and everything
above that which would be excess on your
income and the excess of this million
dollars put percentages on it so I'm
going to put this percentage on my
giving and this percentage on my living
and this percentage on my investing and
I don't care what the percentage is but
then it doesn't matter what you make
you're always going to enjoy some of it
gives some of it an invest some of it
and it's already preset
so you don't think about anymore and
what that does it takes some of the it
causes you to intentionally invest
intentionally be generous and it takes
some of the weird guilt crap off of
enjoying some of it so if you you know I
mean like I got a guy that was with not
long ago he's making ten million dollars
a year okay and he wanted to buy like a
two hundred thousand on our car which is
weird for most people but most people
don't make 10 million ours a year so
it's really a very small percentage of
his world hmm so if he allocates 5%
that's a half million dollars a year to
screw around mmm think about it just to
screw around with I mean that's that's
pretty good blow money that's all right
you know you're getting there so you can
still go buy that car and not think
about it matter fact you could buy two
of them and drive one I'm off a cliff
for fun you know I mean what do you want
to alright so you just put that what it
does it sets you free from all the
weirdness that that many zeros does to
your brain and you can just say I'm
gonna enjoy this
and I'm gonna give this I'm gonna invest
that and that's what I would do in this
situation and it's nothing to do with
maybe step four you need to be
systematically investing a percentage
that you predetermine of your income and
of this me and the remainder of the
million dollars after debt free for the
rest of your life you need to be
systematically giving an outrageously
generous and and by the way with your
numbers it doesn't take it's like his
numbers they're not quite as bizarre but
it doesn't take a large percentage to
have a great life that's right I mean it
really doesn't when you think that kind
of money Dave I've run across a lot of
people I've yet zero never met somebody
who wished they didn't give have you
ever run across that person I've yet to
Christian atheist agnostic mean kind
I've never run across somebody who gave
money that didn't say that was awesome
yeah as a category yeah but I mean I've
had giving experiences that were less
than I wish I'd given something to this
person I get that yeah just as hell or I
gave to this and then I find out later
that it was a dadgum
you know bad thing there you go so or
something like that I've done that but
as a captain ethos or as a category
generosity has brought me more joy with
money than any other cat
anything and that's not just a
philosophical Christian fluffy statement
it's just it's a fact that's right
because it gives you traction
psychologically spiritually you go that
just give me a thousand dollars buys a
single mom who's below the poverty level
a car you bet
changes our life it changes her life ten
thousand dollars does it for ten Wow
I mean it that that that's freaking fun
yeah it is I mean and you have to be you
know intentional and you don't get a
junk car and might be a three thousand
one for my be a thousand but I mean the
point is you're just thinking through
this and you're very precise and very
careful and in order to if and then that
magnifies the joy of it but yeah III
have I have had giving experiences where
I had regret that I wished I hadn't on
it but as a category now hmm never never
never I've never met anybody that did
that said oh I I'm not I don't give and
I'm not a giver well I've met people
that don't give but they're not usually
happy people there you go you know
givers there's a thing about giving
about generosity you know when you say
someone's such a generous person when
someone says that sometimes they mean
that give away money mm-hmm but
sometimes you're speaking as a character
quality that's right it's like that's a
person of integrity
they look me in the eyes that's a person
that smiles yes they're generous they
stay you know they they give of
themselves they they carry the groceries
the car for you and even if they're
billionaire you know they help you pick
up the rolling around all over the
parking lot cuz the bag fell out of the
bottom fell out of the bag or whatever
I got picking them up look at the truck
he gets in yeah usually that's a
generous person and usually they're a
successful person but that's an ethos
that's a way of being it's a character
qua what like all character qualities
it's a choice
that's right you decide you can just
decide I'm a generous person and then
start right now just starting right now
I'm just gonna hold the door I'm gonna
put others before me I'm gonna you know
serve mmm I don't have to be the front
line
you know all that and you can just
decide it's just a decision and you just
walk through life lighter
ohoho much just walk through lighter
much lighter
I'm so proud for you Anthony
congratulations you ma'am and I hope
that all this continues to bless you